all right so yellow jackets episode five
man this is slowly turning into lost
people just keep saying we gotta go back
which I both love and kinda hate because
I need answers there are far too many
questions but welcome back to heavy
spoilers your home of the heaviest of
spoilers and in this video we're going
to be discussing everything in episode
five full on spoilers callbacks and even
more crazy theories get those rubbers
ready because Javi is in love with a
tree woman anyway if you enjoyed this
video hitting that like button is much
appreciated and subscribe to heavy
spoilers to stay up to date on all of
our Yellow Jackets coverage with all of
that out of the way thank you so much
for clicking this I'm your host Jared
now let's get into Yellowjackets episode
5. kicking things off we get a little
peek behind the curtain of Vans life
running the video rental store which is
basically rewinding tapes and tossing
overdue payments into the trash
four non-blondes what's up plays which
is a fitting song because it expresses
renewed appreciation of Life despite
being in a unfavorable mental or social
predicament which both right there fit
Van's current life situation unable to
pay bills and taking oxy pills but
seemingly loving the video rental store
or more of the idea of the past and the
Nostalgia and reliving the 90s because
that was kind of stolen from the yellow
jackets there's a couple of small
details that hinted other events going
on back in the wilderness like the alive
movie on the stairs which follows a
similar plane crash scenario with the
stranded rugby team having to survive
welcome to the dollhouse which is the
movie that she rewinds could also relate
back to Misty because it follows an
unpopular middle schooler as she goes to
the extreme lengths of trying to earn
the respect of her vicious fellow
students similarly to how Misty has been
looked at by the others as a survivalist
van recommends the watermelon woman to a
regular that comes into the store which
surprisingly follows a lesbian working a
day job in a video store AKA ban anyway
van and Taissa have a past it's it's
clear but it's only alluded to a couple
of times I think that this pair honestly
I think that they were engaged decades
ago after the Wilderness there's a
subtle shot of Van without a wedding
ring she is digitizing a wedding video
which she longingly watches a mention of
regrets in the past and taisa says happy
wife happy life back in the wilderness
so I'm curious if moving forward we'll
see more of uh this kind of like a coach
Scott different life situation obviously
Tais is sleepwalking other persona
spells are coming back more frequently
and there's references to this in the
drawing in Vans bathroom with the two
faces along with the Dual paintings
hanging in the kitchen honestly vans
still has a longing for taisa and may be
the only one to crack the secret of why
this sleepwalking has come back because
she knows about quote the other one the
darker version of taisa who steals some
smooches from her but the one mystery
here the one mystery is that Tai is
saying that she's in the wrong place
this isn't where we're supposed to be
kind of feels like a Jack from lost
again another reference but where was
she supposed to be I think that she was
actually supposed to drive to lottie's
instead of Vans taisa had hired Jessica
to keep tabs on all of the yellow
jackets so lottie's information had to
have been in the file from last week but
accidentally or purposely even drove to
Vans instead actually maybe whatever
spirit is at work here is Poland the
strings behind the scenes for all of
them to reunite all of these years later
the slow zoom out of the static
television again makes me think that
there's something more behind the scenes
that is actually happening here we
theorized last week that there might be
some Truman Show like Shenanigans Cabin
in the Woods watching in the wilderness
because more and more static has been
added to Transitions so we'll see if
that's the case hopefully next week but
yeah the static TV and loads of
nostalgia at Vans is is hella sauce
Misty throughout this episode is also
sort of living in the past or the past
is repeating itself because the events
that play out with Crystal back in the
wilderness are eerily mirrored here with
Walter however the outcomes are a bit
different in the wilderness we see
Crystal drawing a two from the deck of
cards with two being designated on duty
flush last week we theorized that the
Queen of Hearts Lottie had hallucinated
might be the person that is put up for
sacrifice when food runs low so seeing
the cards being used a bit more here I
think lends even more to that idea
Misty's questionable ethics seems to be
something instilled in her sense she was
a teen since she was young saying that
Jack Kevorkian was Brave for what he did
Kevorkian was an outspoken euthanasia
proponent which might explain why Misty
ends up working in an assisted living
facility but Misty thinks her bestie
will agree with anything she says
because again their Besties admittee
seen to destroying the plane's emergency
responder but uh yeah things completely
backfire and Crystal turns on Misty
immediately seeing that she is far from
a good actress that's why they're stuck
there in the wilderness resulting in
Crystal plummeting to her death a lot of
this makes sense now we theorize Misty
would turn on crystal somehow in the
wilderness and the love for musicals
hard time making friends in the present
day and not having a problem cleaning up
messes all point back to this moment
this is why Misty winces a little bit
when Staying Alive is playing on the
radio it reminds her of Crystal's death
and trying to give her CPR to the rhythm
of that song Walter persuades Misty into
playing a similar game of two truths and
a lie with him winning but saying
something a bit sketchy I don't think
that you understand the rules of your
own game there's only ever one rule win
this makes me think he's holding back on
what he knows about Misty like all of
the stage played music then the same
game Misty played right before Crystal's
accent something is off about him
especially when he then accuses Misty of
Adam Martin's disappearance Walter knows
more than he's letting on doing his own
research to find out Misty was lying
about talking with Adam's mother
potentially he was hired by someone else
as a private investigator to look into
Adam's case but instead of Misty
threatening his life like Crystal back
in the day she just shrugs it off
however her missing all of Lottie when
keeping tabs on the other Yellowjackets
raises a huge red flag form if she
couldn't find Lottie or know about the
wellness Retreat then what did she
actually know about Lottie did she just
assume Lottie was still in the Swiss
mental hospital the facility I don't
know next week hopefully we get our
answers since she joins the cult at the
end of this episode but but again
Misty's story both the past and present
have allusions to Sherlock Holmes
specifically the short story of the
final problem where in this Sherlock and
Moriarty have a scuffle on a cliff near
the Reichenbach Falls in Switzerland
resulting in the both plummeting to
their death now of course this doesn't
happen exactly beat four beat but
Crystal does fall from the cliff Walter
a few episodes ago mentioned him being a
Moriarty looking for his Sherlock while
lottie's mental institution was said to
have been located in Switzerland so
elements in this are mixed and matched
which may show us that Walter had been
orchestrating brain Misty to Lottie from
the get-go I mean it wouldn't surprise
me if he has a relationship with the
cult too Cali Jeff Shauna and the police
have maybe the most chaotic portions of
this episode with Jay actually taking
Cali on dates which is hella weird I
know he doesn't kiss her it's supposed
to be you know undercut however police
work despite Cali's advances but part of
Jay has the urge to go through with
things I mean it's not too subtle that
the band's lyrics are literally [__] me
and Jay quotes the Jesus from The Big
Lebowski
nobody [__] with the Jesus who was
labeled as a predator for exposing
himself to an eight-year-old in that
movie so Jay yeah Jay you ain't too
innocent buddy however Cali discovering
his real name and occupation throws a
nice Twist on things and sets up a
comedy of errors with Cali lying about
the affair being with Randy and everyone
has to play the part of this
stupid lie you can slowly see Cali
bonding and becoming more like Shauna
through this kitchen conversation which
is going to spell disaster for them in
the future I guarantee it to Cali it's
her finally getting the mother-daughter
relationship that she never had but
Shauna is more than likely using Cali in
her own game of chess so we'll see how
this morphs in the next few episodes but
it's really funny how Shauna and Jeff
just do not say anything to Randy making
him shoot some ropes as a distraction
for Kevin and Jay who of course are
following Shauna a couple things of note
is that Shauna now knows about Natalie's
disappearance and the FBI interrogation
you know uh Misty and Walter a couple
weeks ago but more than likely Randy's
wife separated from him because his junk
just did not work like trying to pick a
lock with some cooked spaghetti this is
why he squeezes lotion into the condom
it's all for show now the thing I'm
curious about is how can any of this
actually be used as evidence any intel J
receives is a bit sketchy her word
against his and breaking into the hotel
room to find a strawberry scented
lotion-filled condom but it really
doesn't prove anything and has gotta be
inadmissible in court so we'll see if
Jay follows through with even more
gorilla investigative techniques because
he and Kevin currently have the upper
hand part of me thinks that Kevin's
missing bullet might actually come back
into play as pun intended ammo for
Shauna to use potentially to uh set him
up she could you know use the gun that
she stole plant Kevin's bullet casing I
I know forensics would probably defeat
this Theory real quick but hey it could
happen last week we left Natalie with
the keys to whatever was in lottie's
closet and no it wasn't the death
records of previous members who were
sacrificed like I had theorized I
honestly thought I was Sherlock Holmes
there with that idea but no it's rather
the banking records phones and personal
property from all of the cult members
obviously Natalie thought she was
blowing the lid off of this conspiracy
by letting the others know what Lottie
was up to but like a wet fart everyone
already knew and handed their belongings
over willingly so a bit anti-climactic
but the real reason Lottie brought
Natalie to her compound is to remember
whatever the heck Travis said Natalie
was right about if you remember back to
season one Misty found a random note in
Travis's plays with tell Nat she was
right written on it and lottie2 wants to
know what she was right about because uh
well Travis uh Travis is unalived from
whatever it was this is why Lottie has
been having Natalie partake in daily
exercises giving voice to her darkest
thoughts is how we gain to our deepest
truths something dark is buried in
Natalie and they attempt to bring this
out with lottie's ritual meditation at
the end of this episode and this is an
extended scene of the weird dream
flashback from episode 2 but it looks
like the last time Natalie and Travis
were together was a motel room drug
party which we were right about when
seeing the paramedics resuscitate
Natalie while Travis looked onward now I
think Nat was right about quote is the
evil presence or Spirit coming back or
had been following them attached to them
ever since they left the Wilderness the
reason Natalie had these Visions was
because she was close to death much like
Lottie in episode 4 and what Travis was
attempting or trying to recreate when he
accidentally ended his own life this
in-between life and death place again a
shout out to 1990s flatliners is where
they can see and talk to this uh spirit
apparently however the only kicker is
that the vision Natalie sees is not what
we saw happen in the wilderness instead
the plane was completely charred and it
looks like there were no survivors I'm
convinced here that this is the same
timeline where coach Scott did not board
the plane and instead got his happily
ever after moment with Paul so part of
me thinks that there's somehow two or
maybe multiple timelines all happening
at once and this 25 years later evil
spirit return is causing these visions
of these two different timelines or
multiple timelines to cross into
unreliable events or memories that the
present day Yellow Jackets can't discern
are either their past or not this would
also explain how their lives each have a
sad depressing kind of dark spot to them
in the dream Vision Natalie also sees
the antler Queen boarding the plane hell
maybe the queen changed things and
brought them all back to life and the
charred plane actually did happen
they've they are all dead bro back to
life but Lottie also sees the silhouette
of the antler queen as she turns
following her own shadow of course
heavily implies Lottie as the antler
Queen but I think otherwise the antler
Queen is actually the seventh member at
the Wilderness cannibalistic Feast that
opens season one the six Yellowjackets
are serving this Force so that would
mean that the six surviving adults of
Shauna Lottie taisa Misty van and Travis
are the ones under the hoods at this
ritual now who or what the antler Queen
is I think ties back to Hobbies drawing
that coach Scott picks up hidden in the
roots of the tree is a woman-like figure
and Javi even says that she told him not
to come back this is the spirit maybe
Mother Nature because throughout this
episode all of the girls do talk to the
forest it could be some other woman or
maybe someone below the ground where
Javi was staying to survive the element
either way I'm saying that the antler
Queen is the one that is tormenting him
here and it could even be the embodiment
of the god Dionysus gender swapped as
the girls have been portrayed as main
ads a couple of times a couple other
things that hint at the group summoning
the antler Queen in present day are the
fact that some of the adult yellow
jackets in this episode are wearing a
similar orange that Lottie was wearing a
color we've seen and said that the
purple people follow like the Sun so
it's no coincidence that Shauna Misty
and Walter all wear it in this episode
with Natalie also having little details
of orange slowly seeping into her outfit
but also there are two random blink and
you miss them frames of Natalie wearing
this white outfit which looks a little
bit more ritualistic like the ritual
scenes in the very first episode of
season one and this transition of old to
Young Natalie symbolizes that they have
to go back to their past and remember
lastly re-watching episode 1 of this
season Paul the guy that works here Mr
heavy spoilers himself mentioned that
lottie's compound specifically where she
gives her speech in the opening could
actually be laid out to look like a
massive symbol from the Wilderness where
she's standing when she speaks is a big
circle like the circle of the symbol
with two rows of followers on each side
creating the two lines protruding on
each side of the triangle the remaining
pieces like the line and the hook have
yet to be seen maybe when they're
walking through talking with Lisa in
episode 2 but if this is true holy sh
people Lottie has been trying to summon
this thing for years maybe we too are
having crazy Visions here at heavy
spoilers and digging way too deep into
things but do you think Lottie is trying
to bring all of the yellow jackets into
the same place to summon whatever this
evil spirit is I mean there's gotta be
something were missing in the wilderness
Lottie has become essentially the leader
of almost all of the girls full on
Wicker man slash Rosemary's Baby Vibes
are spewing from her having the others
listen to the forest speak her influence
continues to grow stronger after the
gift of the birds and the Revelation
that Javi was in fact alive but I'm
saying she is nothing but smoke and
mirrors bad news from Lottie and this is
because the birds a couple weeks ago
let's talk about them because they were
starlings and typically these are seen
as invasive species similar to how the
girls are invasive to the Wilderness but
if we compare this to spirit animals
like we did with the white moose a
couple weeks ago a spirit animal of a
starling suggests careful consideration
as to with whom you spend time and how
much they influence your thoughts and
behavior here you can see most of the
girls are already sided with Lottie much
like the sun covers everything in the
opening pigment and then you know the
sun in glottie's cult later on Shauna
and Aquila are the only ones right now
in the outs of the group because they
see this influence taking hold sure
Akila participates in the forest weird
speak rituals but it's solely for
superstitious reasons like the pre-game
ritual she talks about later before
every game each and I will pump
ourselves up to Easy Lover and then I
will put all my lucky socks and she
would put on her lucky shin guards and
then we would tap our cleats on the line
at the same time before we took the feel
it just it just felt good
kind of made a difference like
we will play better or they will play
worse I mean it's not like we really
believed it
not deep down
this is what is happening with ladia and
all the coincidences in the forest the
group needs to believe in something
whether or not it's actually having any
effect on things like taisa's
sleepwalking all of a sudden stopping
but is it because of Lottie or something
else I can see the belief in Lottie
escalating far more into cannibalistic
practices that we can only assume are
gonna start back up soon ever since last
episode Lottie has become more and more
attuned to the forest and listening to
it which seems to be driving her towards
Shauna's baby it's almost guaranteed
that the baby episode is going to be
next week with this episode ending with
Shauna having contractions and Dan zig's
mother plane Guitar Hero 2 baby and yeah
Lottie has something up her sleeve with
shawna's little bundle of joy whispering
to it in this episode now if you listen
closely I think she says you're going to
change everything
[Music]
thank you
so if that's the case Lottie is
definitely full ongoing Rosemary's Baby
on shawna's baby either it's going to be
possessed by whatever Forest spirit is
out there that lottie's talking to or
it's going to be sacrificed to some sort
of messed up ritual that Lottie has
planned and with her Whispering you're
going to change everything I think that
this is going to fracture the group into
the Rival Civil War Twilight Breaking
Dawn fight like scene that we've briefly
seen in the season 2 intro as for
theories or future reveals I'm still
leaning into there being some sort of
underground mining tunnels where Javi
was living from the elements the weird
melted snow Moss patches could be like
exhaust ports and the tunnels could even
connect to a secret trapdoor in the
cabin basement this would explain how
Javi was able to move around undetected
stealing the bear meat which we assume
was him and also going number two in the
piss bucket his disheveled look on his
face from last week when they all found
him is because he no doubt saw all of
the others eat Jackie that one night and
he is he is just terrified for his own
well-being but also mixed timelines uh
split upper and lower world and mixing
events might be at play here again there
is that quick two-frame shot of Natalie
dressed and all white performing what
looks to be some sort of ritual and back
in episode 3 there is one single hidden
frame of what appears to be coach Scott
being eaten followed by the weird
static-like TV transitions I'm curious
if these static transitions are
purposely showing events out of order or
in those different timelines to confuse
us further but hey that is just our
theories anyway that is episode 5 of
season two I have a feeling this is
setting up some hella Supernatural stuff
in the next couple episodes and I'm
really curious if Lottie is going to
take a page from Rosemary's Baby and
kidnap Shauna's child right after it's
born I guess the biggest thing I want to
know right now is where hobby was and
who this Spirit woman is I'm digging the
ongoing mystery but there's gotta be a
turning point of some answers soon so
what did you think of episode 5 and what
sort of theories or ideas or just
thoughts in general do you have about
what the heck is going on so far let us
know everything in the comments below
and I'll let you know we're currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of Ant-Man Quantum Mania on the
15th of May and all you got to do to get
a chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts of Yellowjackets episode five
we picked the comments at random at the
end of every single month and the
winners of last month are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other cool videos right
over there new stuff Mando season of
finale some old breakdowns check them
out treat yourself but with all of that
out of the way thank you so much for
your constant support I've been Jared
I'll see in the next one take care and
peace